the corona virus is affecting everyone's
life across the globe and that includes
us right here at CBS News six CBS News
employees were diagnosed with Cove in
nineteen and one of them is CBS News
foreign correspondent Seth Doane there
he is
Seth is currently quarantined in his
home in Rome
Seth first let me say it's really good
to see you really good I want to know
number one how you're feeling and what
you were experiencing that made you
think I need to get testing I need to
get tested thanks Gail I was starting to
feel I coughed a little bit just about
enough to worry the people I was with
here we were out working covering this
story I started to have a little bit of
a cough that worried me for the most
part I feel okay as we know this is a
deadly virus it can be incredibly
serious a major respiratory illness so
far I've been lucky I've had a kind of
chest pressure almost like you feel like
you've done a big chest workout I've had
a little bit of a cough I had a
relatively mild fever I've had kind of
weird aches and pains in places I'm not
used to but honestly I feel like I've
had colds and flus worse than us I've
never been totally out for the whole day
in bed I've been up able to talk with
people so for me luckily fortunately for
me it's been a quite mild but as soon as
I learned I had been exposed to people
who had tested positive we have been in
lockdown here inside the houses you know
Italy has been locked down people have
been asked told they have to remain at
home but since I had had exposure to
positive cases I was absolutely not
allowed to leave the house I haven't
even left the house to take out the
trash
in fact our neighbors just brought some
groceries to us and left them on the
front doorstep so we have taken from the
moment I learned that I was exposed to
positive cases we've taken this
quarantine seriously because you have to
stop this red video of you getting the
actual test boy that was hard to watch
it looks very uncomfortable is it as
painful it's very uncomfortable Gail
they really stick this swab up both
sides of your nostrils and then both
sides of the back of your throat you saw
those are how Italian health authorities
who came to
or apartment here in Italy if you're
feeling symptoms you call a number we
also called our local doctor here in
Rome for a while they didn't want to
give me the test because they said you
have very mild symptoms the Italians
have been incredible they've been
checking two times a day in fact one
just called him because my fever I have
a little bit of a fever now he said okay
now we're gonna stop checking two times
a day we're gonna call you three times a
day to check your temperature so they've
been very responsive to stop any spread
they say we can't leave the house
so health authorities suit up in those
space suits protective suits it's quite
alarming to have them come into your
house but they've got to stay safe as
well they came and administered those
tests we waited about 24 hours and I got
the test this weekend so this weekend
since we've heard of some people who are
under quarantine literally having to get
like a form to be able to go out and buy
groceries I mean how else is quarantine
affected your life there a quarantine
has stopped life in many ways here in
Italy if you've been exposed to positive
cases you're not allowed to leave the
house certainly if you are positive
yourself you're absolutely not able to
leave the house and Italians have been
asked to stay at home I have that form
you're talking about here if you don't
have those symptoms if you haven't been
exposed to a positive case you can have
this self-declaration form where you can
go out for medical needs for something
like going to the grocery store or the
pharmacy most everything is closed here
but for instance our neighbor who is
safe and a friend down the street they
very cautiously go to the supermarket
everyone's keeping their distance there
are very few people on the street but
they carry this form with them in case
they're stopped by police that's one
thing I hadn't thought about until just
this morning but I think it's really
interesting is when you have this virus
you then call people that you've had
contact with to say look I tested
positive what's that call like and how
do people react Tony it's awful this is
not what I want to be discussing on TV
it is not what I want to be known for
but I'm trying to be public and open
because I think it's vital that we stop
the spread of this thing it is vital
that people inform people they've had
contact with I took it very personally a
psychological part for me has been worse
than the
than the physical part and I've tried to
call or email or contact everyone I had
contact with I was feeling great I felt
totally fine
luckily our amazing doctor Jon LaPook
has been in touch with me every day and
checking and he hopes that I wasn't
spreading at that point when I when I
was feeling terrific but really it's too
early we don't know but I've taken it
very seriously to call everybody I had
contact with as difficult as it's been
to say you've got to take this seriously
you have to quarantine Seth now that you
have it do you just wait it out it's not
like you're taking medication right you
just wait for it to pass no there's
there's no treatment exactly Gail
there's waiting at home they say look
you have it all you can do is stop the
spread inside your house I'm trying to
be careful of my husband who tested
negative so far so we're trying to keep
a distance I'm trying to sterilize as
much as I can in a house but the idea is
that it stops at my doorstep well Seth
that is really great to see you and it's
also great to hear that you're doing
okay at least for now we hope things
stay stable and you you whether through
this quarantine well good to see you